in good shape your health magazine on DW
featuring an interview with a different
expert every week
to learn more about psoriasis I'm
talking with dr. Ludwig patch here you
head of the dermatology department in
this clinic yeah thanks for inviting me
today yeah you're really fighting
against psoriasis so so what changed in
the strategies of the therapy over the
last year's so in the last decades the
treatment of psoriasis has changed a lot
because a new class of substances has
been introduced for treatment they are
called biologicals and these are
monoclonal antibodies or receptor
antagonists which target inflammatory
molecules of the psoriasis directly and
these are treatments which cannot cure
psoriasis but they are highly effective
so they modify the immune response in
psoriasis or what do they entail strikes
- yes they modify the immune response by
antagonizing key cytokines of the
psoriatic inflammation and which
patients do subscribe those drugs so
first of all you would check how severe
is the psoriasis and how bothersome it
is for the patients if patients have
only mild psoriasis they usually go well
with topical treatment however if they
have moderate to severe psoriasis
topical treatment and also photo therapy
is of not sufficient so 30 therapy is
treating with the lights for the therapy
is treating with UV light for example
narrowband UVB which is also effective
in reducing the inflammation of the skin
yeah and you have then you have a
traditional systemic agents which you
take orally and you have the biologicals
the biologicals are approved for
moderate to severe psoriasis and they
are sometimes more effective than the
traditional systemic agents but they are
also more cost intense but isn't it
dangerous to modify the immune system
and to suppress the immune system to get
rid of the inflammation one hand side
but the other thing is if you if you
would put slow it down immune system
what about infections one of the major
side effects of biologics is
that they can cause infections most of
these infections are mild
for example as NASA pharyngitis upper
airway infection but reality also severe
infections can occur if we have your
patient with us today I met him yeah
thanks and thanks for joining us and and
you're treating her topically so with
the chemo what is it but those are not
biological time this is agreement which
causes an irritation of the skin and by
this irritation also down regulation of
the inflammation and this cream has been
introduced into treatment of psoriasis
already at the beginning of the of the
20th century so more than hundred years
ago yeah but and the patient is not
treating herself with the cream there's
a nurse helping so why is that
I can't just take the cream at home
until the cream is irritating for the
skin and this is why the concentration
has to be increased correct yet
gradually to start with a very low
concentration and you increase step by
step as tolerated is it chance that you
can cure psoriasis and then your future
you will not be able to cure psoriasis
in the near future however you are able
to treat just quite effectively and you
we are able to find suitable treatment
for the vast majority of patients we got
a viewer question from nuts AG grant
dalla and she wants to know and what can
she do as a patient to treat herself and
to influence the disease next to the
doctor so what is important is a healthy
lifestyle because psoriasis can be
associated with comorbidities for
example patients with moderate to severe
psoriasis have an increased risk of
diabetes and of cardiovascular disease
and this is why they should do sports
they should take healthy food and take
care not to be overweight and avoid
smoking and avoid drinking too much
alcohol and then it is essential to use
moisturizing skin care for example the
urea to keep the skin soft and smooth
and in addition avoid stress if possible
think it absolutely try to inviting me
today into your clinic and things that
we could join you today thank you so
much